your brand is are you yeah whatever you
did was it any good not how many likes
to get something you never had you have
to do something you never did you son
got shot in the face that's difficult
making a movies is a luxury wanna soar
get a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best Denzel Washington and some of his
best life-changing advice mentor me
Denzel okay let's kick it off with rule
number one aim for quality not quantity
the movie business I tell my two
children under actors especially in
movies you want people to go away I
can't wait to see him right you know not
oh I see him everywhere oh so so we
talked about this do you think that some
of the actors and the actors that are
you know constantly saying come see me
come see me do you think that's a
mistake I think if you drink too much
water you'll drown so uh yeah you you
want to keep some mystery you know keep
things quiet so that you build up to
that next movie where is he what I mean
when's the last time you saw Daniel
day-lewis
listen branding for an actor is being
good not being known your brand is are
you yeah whatever you did wasn't any
good not how many likes rule number two
bring your dreams to life my wife told
me this great expression to get
something you never had you have to do
something you never did Les Brown's a
motivational speaker you made an analogy
about this he says imagine you're on
your deathbed and standing around your
deathbed are the ghosts representing
your unfulfilled potential the ghosts of
the ideas you never acted on the ghosts
of the talents you didn't use and
they're standing around your bed angry
disappointed and upset they say we came
to you because you could have brought us
to life they say and now we have to go
to the grave together so I ask you today
how many ghosts are going to be around
your bed when your time comes also if
you want to have confidence like Denzel
and other black entrepreneurs check out
my 254 black excellent series the link
is free and it's in the description
below failed
that's right feel big you only live once
so do what you feel passionate about
passionate about you're looking for an
excuse you'll find one in race you can
find it wherever you like you son got
shot in the face that's difficult making
a movie is a luxury it's a gift
rule number three fell big there is no
ceiling for you really there's nothing
you can I don't think is it you know I
mean all are you selling anyone there's
no ceiling you know because I mean
you've proven that you can you can cover
the whole waterfront in terms of kinds
of characters yeah whether the it's a
boxer or a quadriplegic or someone it
was a brilliant lawyer the whole range
of stuff hmm you know with the training
that I had that's the way we were
trained you know to play any part isn't
there's no such thing as you can't play
a party may not be right for a
particular part yeah
but I don't think there's a part I can't
attempt to play I could at least analyze
and try to break down and put a
performance together may not be any good
yeah but I was taught one of the things
that I was taught that sticks in my mind
was a gentleman by the name of Bill ball
who was the artistic director an
American Conservatory Theater in San
Francisco and he always talked about
failing big so if you're gonna fail fail
big I like that for I do too
you know I'm not a fallback mentality
kind of person people would say well you
know you better have another career to
fall back on I'm like I don't want to
fall back on anything if I fall I'm
gonna fall forward I want to see what
I'm hitting or buy you exactly you know
what I mean I don't want to burn I never
understood that mentality neither I
never understood it I'm like I'm going
that way yeah I mean if you worried
about being safe and secure and security
well if security is your byword then you
know you're gonna you're never gonna
reach out and do anything I don't think
that's gonna protect you that's right
you know it's gonna give you any kind of
genuine satisfaction in life you could
feel worried about that then you know it
was in other words if you're a sailor
you would never leave port right I only
care about security
there was an IQ the question I think was
an IQ question where they had nine dots
yeah and you had to connect the dots I
think with five the lines without
lifting the pencil the only way you
could do it was to go outside the box
yeah you know when people sit there with
it go out man that's right you can't do
it what you can't nobody said you can't
go outside the box yeah you know rule
number four stick to your gun you don't
have to compromise yourself you know it
is something you don't feel good about
then don't do it the most important
choices I made was to say no I said no
many a time to films that I just did
especially early on that just didn't
feel comfortable there was one scoop
that was brought to me I call that the
negative you couldn't kill
use juice ratings wife
in the 40s and they try to hang on
everybody didn't die
so I actually I was fortunate at that
time to instill to be able to call and I
said you know this movie make it I'm
sick and they offered me six hundred
thousand dollars later they couldn't do
he said to me and I'll say this to you
he said the first two or three or four
films to make a dissenter free dental
will determine how you ever see
he said I'm not going to tell you what
to do but remember that the first three
or four or five of you making the turn
right on your receipt I turned it down
our turn winding down I needed money
turn it down six months later I got
tried freedom
if you don't feel like I should do it
then don't do it because you don't want
to be you know you don't want to be a
negative energy on the set that's how I
feel something you know or I ain't doing
this is I'm going to slap somebody the
second day
decision tonight actress is saying no
they saying no we have to rule number
five put things in perspective I was a
garbage man won't like Troy huh you get
eight hours worth of work but you can do
it in three so you can go home as soon
as you finish post office you get three
hours worth of work and you make it last
eight I did both I like being the
garbage man better but they weren't bad
jobs it's like a human people's hole the
difficulty of making a movie I'm like a
send your son in Iraq that's difficult
it's just a movie it's like relax I
don't play that precious nonsense oh
whoa get out of here you know your son
got shot in the face that's difficult
making a movie this is a luxury it's a
gift it's an opportunity and most
importantly it's a gift obviously
everybody here is talented enough to do
that but don't get it twisted it's just
a movie ain't that big a deal now I've
got a really special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching a
video they're taking action in your life
for business here we go question number
one where do you need to stick to your
guns number two what dream of yours do
you need to bring to life and number
three what's the perspective shift that
you need to make
what was that break what was that moment
that you felt like I'm still waiting do
you actually feel that way because when
I watch your movies a person who have
done so much it feels like you could
shut it down it's not a competition and
and I'm not competing against others I'm
just trying to get better that's why I
act on stage act in the movies and
direct and produce cuz I like new
challenges
if you want more Denzel check out the
top ten rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there you're looking for an
excuse you'll find one in race you can
find it wherever you like
you know I'm an ordinary man with an
extraordinary job